[Musique]
bienvenue on est au départ du trou
numéro 15
donc le trou numéro 15 en fait c'est un
trou assez emblématique en va du
parcours de l'albatros parce qu'en fait
c'est celui qui va permettre aux joueurs
de rentrer dans l'arène où on va trouver
les quatre derniers trous dont 15 16 17
18 sur lesquels il va se passer
certainement beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de choses à la fin du mois ce trou
l'hameçon annoncé le juge
c'est un parent par 4 qui fait 373 m
donc ce n'est pas forcément très long
mais qui est quand même assez intimidant
pourquoi parce que les bayards du monde
encore une fois parce que
à le faire où et quand même relativement
étroit avec l'eau qui est quand même
assez présentes sur sur la partie droite
et leur offre encore une fois très
présent sur la partie gauche
hélas la mise en jeu sera primordiale
pourquoi parce que les gars sont là pour
combattre son parcours sur lequel la
stratégie est prépondérante et c'est un
parcours sur lequel il est important de
réfléchir au coup suivant
hélas le trou numéro 15 le résume camama
c'est bien parce que la mise en jeu sera
comme je le disais primordial avec un
coût qui devrait être quand même
assez assez conséquent assez fort assez
puissant sur la partie gauche du fairway
de façon à ce que le joueur puisse avoir
un petit club pour l'attack de grid ça
reste quand même l'endroit le plus
stressant car la tacc de green sur ce
trou là est vraiment le coup le plus on
va dire le plus oppressant et le plus
stressant que les joueurs vont pouvoir
rencontrer tout au long de ce tournoi
[Musique]
donc là on est sur la position idéale
peu après une mise en jeu de façon à
pouvoir attaquer attaquer le green du
trou numéro 15
ici la difficulté c'est ça va être si le
6 le drapeau est positionné devant et à
l'entrée du lean pourquoi parce qu'en
fait c'est la partie la plus étroite
mais c'est un trou également sur lequel
souvent le vent dominant et un vent
avant qui va venir ici lé de la gauche
c'est qui va obligatoirement pousser les
balles qui seront pas très bien contrôlé
pas très bien touché sur l'obstacle
d'autres qui situe on va dire qui
entoure le green et qui est vraiment
très oppressant sur la partie droite de
ce crime
l'autre chose également qu'il faudra
prendre en considération par la ryder
cup c'est c'est la foule qui va y avoir
tout autour de ce trou là parce que là
on est vraiment dans une arena c'est
vraiment une arène golf x1 stadium c'est
tout ce que vous voulez les rares du
monde dans les tribunes no18 d'autres
tribunes du cadre et tribune du trou
numéro un
toute la foule qui va pouvoir entouré ce
trou lame très honnêtement je pense que
mon est en capacité ici l'accueillir à
peu près 30 35 mille spectateurs et
35000 spectateurs qui vous regardent de
taper ce coup-là déjà que quand on le
joue sans spectateurs c'est un trou qui
est vraiment très stressant et très
oppressant alors avec toutes ces paires
d'yeux qui vous regardent ça peut être
quelque chose d'assez terrific pour les
joueurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans car on est sur le green du trou
numéro 15 ce green du trou numéro 15 est
assez particulier on va dire parce que
c'est un green qui est à la fois l'umq
est à la fois large qui tenteraient doki
avec énormément de pente
on peut avoir beaucoup de pente au fond
à droite beaucoup de pente devant
également l'entrée du gris sur ce coup
là beaucoup de potes de france se sont
joués on a eu des joueurs qui ont gagné
1 grâce à des perf où beaucoup de
joueurs comme idée balle dans l'eau qui
sont retrouvés sur les trois derniers
trous en ayant vu un tournoi passer
devant veut parce que se trouve la les
avaient pénalisé
[Musique]